we must
protect um and fight to protect
our our freedom to speak our mind
however oh challenging
it is with certain people to hear them
um
you know we there is where is the line
you know that line is always it's always
a difficult conversation to have
you know about um abortion and
the the the line of freedom of speech
incitement to violence well what is
violence
are words violence i remember reminded
of ricky gervais who said offense isn't
given it's only taken
you know if you choose to take offense
then take it um
i'm not giving it right and it's not
tragic if you're offended the idea that
we're supposed to remake
civilization to avoid you being offended
uh
that's a that's a dire prescription
right there
yeah and i think we what i've been doing
with the respondent and why i started
the respondent is to try and just
begin a conversation a multimedia
conversation
um and part of it came came about
through this
you know we talk about the fact the
founding fathers the the constitution
and
america and where we are today part of
it came out of this
toxic masculinity um smashed the
patriarchy
all men bad and there were so many men
being cancelled
some of them were you know justifiably
tried in the court of public opinion and
then um
tried in the in the legal system but
some i think were caught up
particularly in my business in the
entertainment industry without
due process and you know
trying to return a place where chivalry
i feel like chivalry is is dead or it's
it's been lost i'm reminded of uh
i forget who wrote the quote but uh
but it goes but the mind of man
is not like fourier's heated
body continually settling down
into an ultimate quiet
uniformity the character of which we can
already predict
it is rather like a tree shooting out
branches
which adapt themselves to the new
aspects
of the sky towards which they climb and
routes which contort themselves
among the strange strata of the earth
into which they delve
and when i think of that and i think of
congeniality and how to be a more gentle
man and the origins of chivalry which i
think
um they go back to it was a code of
conduct
i think developed in the 13th century
and the ideas of chivalry
and how to be more silveric
how can we even begin to have that
conversation
if we are canceling meant the very idea
of man
is extinct smash the patriarchy as i
understand it
the matriarch and the patriarch is the
mother figure and the father figure
and um what are we gonna do we're gonna
suggest
smashing the matriarch and toxic femme
no that's just the shame rage and the
point counterpoint and you know
most of us i think uh most of us men i
would like to think
uh are not
looking to smash ourselves and tell
ourselves that we are all toxic
yeah uh well first of all i very much
liked that recitation
i've never heard it before but uh it's
it's brilliant
the issue of what is happening to
masculinity is so
dire and you know you say that some
people were tried in the
court of public opinion and then tried
in an actual court
and others were just tried in the court
of public opinion but even more
distressing than that is the fact that
some people were tried
in the court of public opinion for
things that aren't even wrong
yeah and it's guilty till proven more
guilty
not even guilty till we're even innocent
or innocent or proven guilty
and that is what really concerns
me particularly in the area of family
law is one place
um you know the respondent deals with
with the familial bond the familial
tapestry of how we
collectively as a community and
interpersonally within our
marriages relationships um
father son mother daughter etc etc
how do we tend to that into
communication
skill interpersonal communication i
think most of us are vaguely familiar
with stories of family breakdown
or familial breakdown we have a friend
or a or a family member who endured a
bad breakup it's a common trope in our
dramatic
and comedic entertainment and real
obviously reliable fodder for
places media outlets like tmz and
supermarket tabloids
when it comes to celebrity relationship
implosions in particular
i think that there's there's this notion
this
this thought that men
and particularly celebrity men and i
don't classify myself in that
bucket super human
and they're not we're not we're
just human beings and every individual
is struggling with something
and as we are trying to remain
physically um
physically uh healthy within the
organism
we have to remind ourselves to exercise
from the neck up
i think mental health is a huge huge
um issue right now
it was particularly with men we don't
because we don't talk about
it um you know particularly with covid
and this this
messaging of social distancing which
i've mentioned you before is is so
inherently flawed it should be physical
distancing and social connectedness
we are human beings we're sentient
creatures we we um
we should be encouraged to come together
as small groups and larger groups and
and in in and be communal and um
there's a lot of currently i've i've
seen a lot of commentary
on um this topic of man
being bad and we're bombarded by
messages about the deeply corrosive
effects of
toxic masculinity and confronted with
institutions
psychologically conditioned now to think
masculinity
is toxic that men are bad uh
man's kindness is extinct chivalry is a
bygone notion
and um particularly in the family law
system
it's rife with outdated gender ideas
every bit of sexist
as those faced by women in
other arenas past and present and we
need to spirit level the sexes somewhat
so uh i i very much like this topic i
have a lot of thoughts on it myself and
i believe that
the sexes are up for a renegotiation
but that that renegotiation
would be insane to implement some kind
of
sameness to enforce it in any way
in other words i believe strongly that
there are
features of masculinity that are
honorable and that we must preserve
there are parallel features in the
feminine world
that we need to honor and preserve we
should leave people the freedom
to avail themselves of these things
irrespective of what sex they
are are born in but
we should not expect men to be
like women or vice versa we should find
out what people want when they're truly
liberated
you know in my case um my wife
is lovely but she does
have a kind of male bent she she plays
like a boy
and the animus has risen within heather
yes
and you know it's a great thing i i i'm
very pleased to have a a partner to go
adventuring with
and somebody who doesn't shy away from
danger or pain or all of these things so
it's you know it's not like
uh it's not like i want to go back to
the 50s
right and sometimes that's how it's
portrayed at the same time
i think we are doing a tragic disservice
especially to our boys in telling them
that masculinity is um a hazard or is
inherently bad or something like this
because among other things i may have
said this to you already i
i can't remember but the fact is
straight women do not like weak men
and so if you induce your boys to become
weak you're setting them up for a tragic
romantic failure and this yeah and i
agree with you and you have said that to
me
uh before and i i couldn't agree more
that
how the the mother and father if we're
talking in in simple terms or the
matriarch and the patriarch negotiate
these differences of opinion
of parenting i think is is so that the
child gets the most opportunities to
take risks
but not risks that will kill or severely
injure
him in the case of boys because i'm a
man and i have boys
it's not sexist i'm not you know
not talking about girls and women for
that reason
i think that's vital i remember the
first time my son squared off
to fight physically and i reassured my
wife at the time
that it was a necessary rite of passage
and as our youngest
i think he was six maybe at the time
and my eldest was eight so there's a
two-year age gap
they needed that experience that
prideful moment
he needed the younger brother because
i've been the younger brother of taking
his elder brother on and maybe even
teach him a lesson
in the process which he did a couple of
times
and she was still somewhat distressed as
i led the boys into the back garden or
backyard
and created this imaginary boxing ring
although she did she trusted well trust
is important it's it's vital she trusted
me enough to
to calm her understandable mother bear
concerns
uh to believe that i might know maybe
better how to handle this rush of
testosterone situation and this sort of
balanced parenting
cannot take place if men and fathers
aren't present there must be a balanced
or renegotiation as
i say the spirit level of the sexes in
order for boys to become more fully
formed self-actualized young men take
those rights of passage with a deeper
more imagined sense of healthy
boundaries
so that they can eventually alone
take those steps to start to think like
men
responsibility equals reward and feel
like boys risk taking equals ambition
and i think more we can advocate
fatherhood you know advocating
fatherhood is not about admonishing or
diminishing motherhood
i believe a the primary role of a father
or
one of the primary roles is to maintain
an aura a
presence if you will which says look and
listen son
life has problems we're going to solve
that problem
together one day um
you'll have you'll have your you'll
leave home and
and be playing more seriously on your
own
with your own little children
boys of your own maybe or friends sons
and daughters to play with
tend to be responsible for let's prepare
for that day
to learn how to confidently and sensibly
risk take
together and i think it's vital for boys
to learn
through the eyes and the experience and
the behavior
reflected from a father and to learn
boundary setting
self-discipline and how to instill a
sense of
empathy for themselves their partners
peers and friends
and eventually um you know their
ultimate partner
hopefully and when the testosterone in
boys is not channeled well
boys become destructive and when
father's not present in a family home to
instruct
boys destruct and when testosterone is
channeled well
boys become constructive so why aren't
we advocating
why aren't we talking about positive
masculinity and positive father figures
fathers role models more so that we can
leave a legacy for the
for the younger generations that we
leave behind
so i want to connect a couple threads if
i can manage to do it
your your theme about the constructive
aspect of masculinity is very important
and near and dear to my
heart and i have the sense
that we are very complex creatures i
mean that's
a fact and that what that means is that
the way things are hooked together
is often not obvious and so there's this
tendency
this uh chesterton's fence problem where
something
the purpose of which is not totally
obvious gets removed because
a strong argument can be made that it's
somehow antiquated
and that very frequently we are living
the harm
that arises from having eliminated
something vital without realizing we
were doing it
and what i see on this topic is
that we have renegotiated
the rules of sex
and that those rules of sex basically we
are
told that any resistance to just
getting laid and not thinking about the
consequences
is somehow oppressive
and that the discovery that sex is just
a biological drive and that you could
follow it where it leads you
and there's no reason to make it more
than it is and all of that there's no
reason even really to give a damn about
the person
that you're having sex with that the
consequences of this are many
and one of them is that it puts males
in one of two modes and it's not the one
that we should want
to flourish right men have always had
the opportunity
to spread their seed without taking
responsibility for the consequences
and that is not men at their best that's
men at their worst
and the problem the reason that we are
now hearing about toxic masculinity
is that in a world where men have been
told that that part of them is just fine
and they should
you know activate it is a world that is
dangerous
to women because the men are viewing
them as
targets rather than as partners
and in that world there's this
temptation to then write the rules that
make
women safe to be around men rather than
writing rules in which men are
prone to behave more honorably because
frankly
it's the only path to a life worth
living
and i guess the final thing i would say
on this is that
in a world where sex had not been
demystified
and where it was therefore
difficult to come by and required real
investment by men in order to persuade
women to go to bed with them
men moved mountains in order to impress
the women that they were most interested
in and that was
a process that was tremendously powerful
and the fact that these things are now
frequently
satisfiable with a kind of junk level of
sex
is resulting i think in a great deal of
potential just being
absolutely squandered because there's no
motivation to follow it
[Music]
you